So the big question at this point is, how
is this DNA code like a recipe? And how
is it turned into protein, actually, technically? So this
is a picture of a typical human cell, and
almost all of the DNA can be found inside
the nucleus, here you can see represented by the
chromosomes. But out here in the cytoplasm of the
cell. We see these black dots which are representing
ribosomes, and ribosomes are the machines that will
build proteins. So if ribosomes are the molecular machines
that will build proteins from amino acids and
they're located out here in the cytoplasm and the
information that we need to make the protein
is actually here in the nucleus. How do you
think the cells going to solve this problem of
having the informations segregated away from the machinery needed
to actually build proteins. This is a real physical problem
that has to be overcome. Now some of you may already
know the answer to this question, but if you don't, I
really want you to think about how you might solve this
problem if you were at cell. The information's in the
nucleus, the machinery to build the proteins in the cytoplasm. How
are we going to solve this problem? So don't worry about getting
this right or wrong, per se. Just think of a plausible
way that you might solve this problem, or a way that you think
a cell could solve it. And enter it into the text box here.